ouais ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est réalisable dès lors qu'on met en
place toutes les mesures qui permettent
d'accompagner le plus efficacement
possible la reprise ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire des règles d'indemnisation
chômage qui sont adaptés ça veut dire la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi
étaient mobilisés de manière efficiente
et pertinente et ça veut dire un certain
nombre de mesures d'accompagnement
efficace et non le télétravail va être
beaucoup plus important qu'il ne l'était
avant le coc vide mais il ne deviendra
pas pour autant la norme
il ne faut pas oublier que le
télétravail n'est possible que pour un
certain nombre d'activités est par
exemple tout ce qu'on appelle
communément les cols bleus qu'il n'est
pas question de télétravail et il ne
sera pas question pour eux de
télétravail donc il faut prendre garde à
ne pas accroître dirait le gap entre les
cols blancs et les cols bleus via le
télétravail
on conseiller ça reste quelqu'un qui
doit garder un certain recul par rapport
à ceux qui proposent qui doit être
convaincu par ce qu'ils proposent mais
qui doit garder à l'esprit le fait que
celui qui décide c'est le ministre il
finit donc après vous avez certaines
périodes vous allez être écoutés parce
que vous allez mettre sur la table un
certain nombre d'idées pertinentes et
puis des périodes où le ministre va
choisir une autre direction
lequel s'est vu que vous proposez et
c'est très bien comme ça c'était
compliqué parce que on était dans une
situation où il y avait une contestation
même de la notion de représentation d'un
groupe dès lors qu'une personne sortait
la tête et voulait parler au nom de ce
groupe elle était tout de suite dire est
désigné à la vindicte populaire par
l'ensemble de ses collègues est
disqualifié durablement par l'ensemble
de ses collègues
oulala je les aime bien tous les deux
donc vous savez c'est compliqué de me
poser ce genre de questions moi je suis
resté très proche de tous les deux tout
les ministres et du premier ministre
avec lesquels j'ai travaillé qui sont
des personnes exceptionnelles
[Musique]